[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number
79 79 totally
that's the most quizzical moment of the
day it is the most quizzical yeah what's
gonna happen next it's always exciting
but there's a lot going on a lot of
really interesting stuff in fact there's
so much going on that there's no way we
can do it in one live stream so some of
the things that are going on this week
we may have to return to next week
of course and um you know we i never
assumed that this was a news show so i
am eager to not
feel compelled to um speak to the things
that are going on right now
oh i don't i don't mean it that way i um
unfortunately i think that is a lot of
what we're doing today uh we are going
to talk about some of the new stuff
emerging in in sars kobe 2 space
uh some of uh some of what's happening
in portland some of what's happening
at uh our former institution of higher
ed evergreen
and then a little bit on nature red and
tooth and claw which
is is where i prefer to spend my time
right rather than human nature red and
tooth and claw which is
so much of where we spend our time it's
a special case that's the way i think of
it it's like it's like
nature by other means yeah
yep all right so where are we headed
first
uh well first um just a few
reminders uh that we encourage you to
subscribe
to join us at either of our patreons
brett just had one of his monthly
conversations on his patreon this
morning
you can access on either of our
patreon's discord server uh
and we answer uh for instance a question
from the discord server every week in
our q
a um and um
and maybe that's that's announcements
for now um if you have questions about
logistics
not questions for the q a but questions
about logistics you can always email
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com as well um
so yeah i think we're going to start um
by picking up on a conversation that we
began last week with then brand new
uh research that had come out from um
you know i
say from the salk institute of course
just um wander maybe a couple of the
researchers is at the selk institute but
of course it's a team of researchers
um and just a reminder we we introduced
this research last week
uh i at that point could not uh get
access to the paper i still don't know
why but
um very quickly after we finished airing
um
we finished streaming there was
there was a an abundance of
of the papers came came to us i'm sorry
just a minute there is chaos going on
under the table so i should just point
out while heather is dealing with this
that
we are you know new to the public eye in
this realm
and you know seasoned professionals
would certainly have some way of dealing
with renegade cats who had gotten into
the studio and were making trouble we
on the other hand have uh only the tools
at our disposal and our
hands our hands and uh yeah here's the
troublemaker in question
yeah well he's this was an editorial
comment by him when he was playing with
the
the cables below the table um proceeding
from the fact that he's not getting as
many treats
lately as he as he as he once was so
okay apologies for that
um so last week um
i we were only speaking from what we
could see
on basically the press release on the
sulk institute website
and um just just a reminder first from
in terms of what we said last week from
the salk institute website
um we read a couple of excerpts as
follows
in the news so they're they're speaking
about research that had just been
published in
boy i don't mean it's like circulation
research i think is the name of the
journal
in the new studies in the new study the
researchers created a pseudo virus that
was surrounded by the tsar's kovi 2
classic crown of spike proteins but did
not contain any actual virus
exposure to the pseudovirus resulted in
damage to the lungs and arteries of an
animal model
providing proving that the spike protein
alone was enough to cause disease
tissue samples showed inflammation
endothelial cells lining the pulmonary
artery walls
and later in that same piece they said
this is the first study to show the
damage occurs when cells are exposed to
the spike protein on its own
so since last week we have been able to
read the actual paper
and thank you again to the many of you
who forwarded it and also i was just
able to access it after
after i stream um as well as a new
statement from the authors
in which they say that they're
clarifying what they think the
implications of their work is
as well as a blog post from a researcher
in drug discovery
uh who has a regular blog in science
with his take
um and we've also noted changes to the
salk institute's
uh news release uh which of which
there's no indication on the site itself
they don't indicate that they've
actually changed
the changes are present but it does not
acknowledge that there is a change right
and um we'll we'll we'll get to that you
know it's fairly common to change posts
um but in this case um the
the change was distinct enough that uh
if we hadn't actually shown my screen so
that it was clear what was up at the
time that we were talking about it it
would look like we had been
disingenuous or even dishonest in our
you know so it's possible to miss
something
but not in this case it was right at the
top um so the the change is right at the
top and um i have you know i have
screenshots from
last week and now to show and in fact
there's now but an additional change so
um but we'll get there the original
paper
um is is this and we will
um we will post
um zach please can you show this um
we will um put a link to
not this is a pdf but um put a link to
the
the url where you can find this again
like i said published in circulation
research
by a team of researchers including some
at the salk institute
titled sars kovi to spike protein
impairs endothelial function
via down regulation of ace ii and
um it's a short paper it's a dense paper
um you know very short very dense really
not
sufficient to um you know fully assess
but i will uh highlight and read this
last
this last sentence in which they say
this conclusion suggests that
vaccinated generated antibody and or
exogenous antibody against
s protein not only protects the host
from cyrus cov2 infectivity
but also inhibits s-protein-imposed
endothelial injury
okay so
uh thank you zack um i also wanted to
before we start talking about
um about that i will say that that that
from them which is again the last
sentence of their paper
in which they seem to say yeah you know
we don't think this has bad implications
for
the the mrna and dna vaccines which
obviously as we all know code 4
the spike protein but it wasn't clear to
me
what that why that sentence was there
for like what it followed from
here is a statement so zach you can show
my screen again a statement from the
authors that came out this week
which excuse me
the third paragraph of which reads as
follows
for covet 19 vaccination a small amount
of the spike protein mrna packaged
nanoparticles
pfizer biointact and moderna or spike
protein dna carried by adenovirus
johnson johnson are delivered into
humans through intramuscular injection
the spike protein mrna or dna after
translation to modified
spike protein then function as antigens
to be recognized by antigen presenting
cells for antibody production
so this is um this is what we've been
told this is consistent with everything
we've heard about the vaccines
um and at
finally one more thing to show before we
talk a little bit more before we talk
about what's going on the sulk site
um they link at the bottom um
no actually let's let's just let's just
set this whole thing up first before i
really start talking about it um
this is a
this is not okay it's not working um
i was hoping to show a screenshot from
last week
here we go so this is just from zack
this is from our live stream last week
from the salk institute site in which
you can see
the top sentence reads scientists have
known for a while that sars kobe 2's
distinctive spike proteins help the
virus infect its host
by latching onto healthy cells now a
major new study shows that they also
play a key role in the disease itself
so if i if i may zach
compare that to what the site looks like
as of
uh two days ago um
in which the second sentence
reads now a major new study shows the
virus spike proteins
parentheses which behave very
differently than those safely encoded by
vaccines
also play a key role in the disease
itself so that's been added
there's no reference and really i think
part of what we're going to talk about
here is that this is a claim that is
being made by a lot of people
but i don't think that there's any
experimental evidence at least that i've
seen research evidence
that this is actually true that that the
virus spike proteins
and the vaccine spike proteins
inherently behave differently we hope
they do
and it's suggestive that they might but
we don't actually know this for sure
one more one more
link here if i can
um so this now is the live
site um as of right now
and um they've changed it one more time
which is that they've hot linked
that parenthetical that parenthetical
which says of the virus spike proteins
they behave very differently than those
safely encoded by vaccines
well what's the hot link it's to this
same blog post in science translation
and medicine which is exactly the same
blog post
that the authors of the paper in their
clarification and their author statement
points to
so a couple of things from a blog post
and then i think we've set it up enough
that we can
we can start talking about it um
let me here
yes blog post please
nope so zach please um take off take me
off for a moment
um while i find this because it's not
working
um brett if you want to
yeah while i make my computer do what i
wanted to do all right so
i made it do what i wanted to do okay
um so here is um a pdf of the blog post
and i'm just
i'm going to try to start showing the
pdfs rather than so that i know that
we've captured the moment in time
so this was posted on may 4th spike
protein behavior by a researcher named
derrick lowe who has a regular
blog in i can't remember now i think
it's science translational medicine
and here are just a couple of quotes
from his blog post
he says so i've been getting questions
about what this means for vaccination
relative to this this spike protein
paper out of the salk institute
if we're causing people to express spike
protein via mrna or adenovirus vectors
are we damaging them just as if they'd
been infected with coronavirus
fortunately the answer definite
definitely seems to be no
he says later on now we get to a key
difference when a cell gets the effect
of an mrna nanoparticle or an adenovirus
vector that is the
um mrna vaccines versus the dna vaccines
it of course starts to express the spike
protein but instead of that being
assembled into more infectious viral
particles as would happen in a real
coronavirus infection
this protein gets moved up to the
surface of the cell where it stays
that's where it's presented to the
immune system as an abnormal intruding
protein on a cell surface
the spike protein is not released to
wander freely through the bloodstream by
itself
because it has a transmembrane anchor
region that as the name implies
leaves it stuck later in the same
paragraph
the spike protein produced by
vaccination is not released in a way
that it gets to encounter the ace2
proteins on the surface of other human
cells at all
it is sitting on the surface of muscle
and lymphatic cells up in your shoulder
not wandering through your lungs causing
trouble some of the vaccine dose is
going to make into the bloodstream of
course but keep in mind when the mrna or
adenovirus particles do hit cells
outside of the liver or the site of
injection
they're still causing them to express
spike protein anchored on their surfaces
not dumping it into the circulation so
all of that suggests
that the researchers
and the drug development people
believe that the spike protein that is
produced by the mrna and dna
vaccines is both modified slightly
and its method of of entry into the body
both mean that it will be spreading
much less widely than an organic
encounter with stars kobe 2 in the wild
such that actually this research
suggests that we should feel
better about these vaccines than we did
before this research
that is the conclusion here and i think
it's
plausible but it's not the only
interpretation
well let's just say um a couple things
are going on
one that the idea of the protein
having an anchor that will keep it in
the cell surface is the idealized
version
of what's going to go on so kudos for
designing it in this way and let me put
that in the context
of how the vaccine should should work
under
circumstances where everything goes as
planned so
let's take the mrna vaccine one of them
you've got this lipid nano particle coat
it's covering an mrna it gets into the
body through injection it encounters
some cells for reasons that i think are
still a bit murky it gets taken up that
could be as simple as the nanoparticle
coat being having an affinity for the
membrane of cells that causes it to be
taken up
big asterisk there which cells take it
up
why do they take it up how different is
it how many cells take it up in one
patient versus another these are all
big questions maybe somebody knows the
answer but it's not easy to find even
for somebody who knows that they're
looking for it
um so you've got the mrna
gets dumped into a cell the cell because
all
cells in the body uh make proteins
from mrna messages that are usually
coming from the nucleus of the cell
just simply translates this thing
automatically
and the nature of the protein that gets
translated has this anchor bit in it
that if all goes according to plan
results in it sticking off the surface
of the cell
pointing out at which point the hope is
it will be encountered by antigen
presenting cells which will detect this
cell will effectively take it up and
then present it to a bunch of naive t
cells those of which those that fraction
that tiny fraction of the t
cells that it encounters will react to
it because they are
wired in such a way that they have an
affinity a low affinity at that point
they will
be triggered to diversify then and
selection will
create an ever better affinity for that
spike protein the the short version of
that being the hope
is these cells with the spike protein
having been produced
that are on the surface of them will be
recognized by our immune system
and thus we will be able our adaptive
immunity will
go into effect and um produce a response
such that should we
should the person who is thus vaccinated
encounter
wild-type stars cov2 um their immune
system will then be primed and ready
right it will not be naive even though
they haven't encountered the virus
before
and i should just say that in some sense
what this is
is a benevolent hijacking of the immune
system
because what the immune system is doing
these antigen presenting cells
are maneuvering around the body looking
for
our cells that have been infected so if
your cell has been infected by a virus
it expresses some proteins that are
native to it and it expresses some
proteins that are novel
and so these cells by finding our own
cells that are displaying novel proteins
get an indication of an infection
and then they take the evidence of that
infection to a place
where cells that are capable of
responding to the infection are lurking
the lymph nodes for example
and anyway it accelerates the process by
which your immune system discovers the
enemy
gets a description of it and then
figures out how to recognize it really
well and
creates an army of cells that can then
fight it so what we do
is in this case we trigger
the presentation of this antigen on the
surface of the cell
that is not infected because humanity
those who are deploying the vaccine
we who are vaccinated well scientists
are using i just i'm trying to figure
out what we is here
um we the science technology complex
are triggering human cells in an
uninfected person
to display an antigen as if it was
infected then the antigen presenting
cells take over doing their normal job
collect that antigen display it to cells
that are capable of learning the formula
and responding and the whole thing
unfolds in this way
the problem with this story as deployed
in that blog post
is that it assumes that everything works
as we hope it will
and there's actually very little chance
that that's right because what we are
doing
is completely novel with respect to the
body right we are taking
a uh pseudo virus right a lipid
nanoparticle coat
around an mrna we are infecting a cell
with an
mrna that encodes this one protein
hoping to get it displayed on the
surface but
none of this says that that's what
happens it certainly
is happening enough that these vaccines
do create immunity that is clear
but it does not tell you how much of the
spike protein
is actually going through this process
in the way the textbook suggests and how
much of it is ending up somewhere else
so for example so basically what i see
in this blog post
and all of the analyses that point in
this direction
is a cherry picking of the information
here are all the reasons that this is
probably safe and here are none of the
reasons that it probably isn't
right and the point is you've got a
collection of both reasons they are
correct if this if the
protein anchors in the surface of the
cell and the antigen collecting
cells find it and they take it to some t
cells that get a chance to learn it
then you're not going to have the effect
that these authors found when they
dumped spike protein into the lungs of
what turned out to have been
syrian hamsters okay so we wondered last
week
but that actually turns out to be
important right so
it just so happens that asian hamsters
are one of the animals in which
the accidental elongation of telomeres
has been
observed so hauntings not just the lab
mice
it's the lab hamsters as well right in
fact uh i
have made the claim that it is going to
happen in
the case of all sm all creatures all
mammals
in particular or birds that are small
enough and are bred for profit because
what happens is
when you breed an animal for profit you
want to get as high a return on your
investment in
animal food as you can so you breed
young animals who reproduce faster
and by doing that you destabilize the
mechanism that
creates an equilibrium in telomere
length and you cause elongation so
you've seen it in hamsters
mice rats and domestic chickens i think
you need to spell out i think you just
jumped a bunch of the story and i know
this isn't the place to walk through
all of the logic of antagonistic
pleiotropy and senescence and telomeres
and cancer but
um you just jumped to a conclusion that
may not be clear to
to many lessons and in fact so i would
imagine it's clear to those listeners or
somewhat clear to those listeners who
are
time listeners and have encountered the
telomere story here before but it
it happens the very short version is as
a graduate student i
was studying an evolutionary question
and i stumbled into
a medical question that turned into a
huge haul of mirrors
the upshot is what i was studying was
uh this thing called a telomere which is
a genetic sequence a repetitive genetic
sequence at the ends
of chromosomes and the length of this
sequence
appears to dictate how many times a cell
can reproduce
if you do cellular damage or you need to
do regular maintenance your cells have
to be replaced and so the
length of this telomere dictates how
much replacement you get
and therefore it dictates how
what your maximum longevity is going to
be because basically you've got a pool
of
cells for replacement and when they're
exhausted you suffer the
uh the consequences of aging so why
would selection have built in a limit
like that
the reason it turns out and this was
my contribution in one of my
dissertation chapters is
that if you don't have that limit then
lots and lots of cells in your lifetime
get damaged in such a way that they keep
reproducing and don't stop and they
become tumors which become cancers which
kill you so
in order to avoid that fate a limit has
been built in
to the cellular replication of all uh or
almost all cell lines
so just just to just to tagline it right
like you've identified a fundamental
trade-off
between senescence which is to say
aging-ish
and cancer that you try to beat one and
you're stuck with the other
and there is no way to escape that
trade-off yeah
or another way to put it is your
capacity to do repair and your capacity
to
avoid cancer are in tension with each
other and so what selection has done is
nicely balanced this and given us a very
long life but if you
move in one direction it comes at a cost
to the other so
what does this have to do with what does
this have to do with this so what i
found out was that basically the reason
that people
hadn't figured that out was that there
was one result which made no
sense and seemed to suggest that that
model was wrong which we now know it
isn't but
at the time it seemed like that model
had to be wrong because
mice had ultra long telomeres and very
short lives
and that didn't seem consistent because
they should have the ability to repair
their tissues
for a very long time given that their
telomeres are even much longer than a
human's now it turns out that is to say
you should expect with long telomeres
that their lives would be longer
yes although i i believe i'm just
translating what you just said is that
not yes
okay and in fact in some ways this is
true their lives aren't longer but their
capacity to deal with damage
is better by a lot the reason that their
lives aren't longer is because
we have basically turned off their
cancer protection and so they all get
cancer and they all
die early not all mice
but you're specifically talking about
like we didn't expect to be going down
but i think it's necessary um you're
specifically talking about lab mice
so this isn't wild mice wild mice do
have
um short lives but in the literature
what you found was well mice have long
telomeres
and part of what you said was i wonder
if in fact all mice or if this is in
fact a lab artifact
right and and here you go so i made a
prediction which was actually if you
test wild mice you will find that they
have short telomeres
which in fact turns out to be true so
that was a a coup
there that i was able to predict that
without laboratories or
mice but anyway that turned out to be
accurate
the mystery from the point of view of
the field um
was why are the telomeres getting
elongated and what i think the field has
still not
understood and certainly not owned up to
is that it's the breeding protocol so
initially when this was discovered those
few people who paid attention to it
thought it was going to be the
inbreeding that inbreeding somehow
elongates telomeres which it doesn't
right nor is there any reason it should
it creates problems for sure but it's
not that way it creates
um mentally [ __ ] mice who have other
pathologies
but um it doesn't elongate telomeres
what does elongate telomeres is
breeding only young animals so this is
the only hypothesis left standing as far
as i know for the elongation of
telomeres it's mine
and the hypothesis is by which you mean
all the other hypotheses for the long
telomeres have been falsified have been
falsified
right um so i would say that this one
has the presumption
of truth uh and there's some evidence we
won't go into it but
um in any case the point is when you
breed only young animals because
you're interested in your financial
bottom line and you want to turn
mouse chow into mice at the highest
possible rate so your profit is the
greatest at the end of the day
you breed these young animals you're
breeding animals who are too young to
have died of cancer so therefore the
penalty for being
very prone to cancer is zero or close to
it in evolutionary terms whereas
the advantage evolutionary advantage in
these breeding colonies
to animals that ratchet up and keep at a
high level their reproductive rate early
in life
is extreme and so the point is you're
now selecting
for mice that breed an incredibly high
rate
right and you're not selecting that they
maintain their cancer protection what
you do is you end up creating a species
that's
hyperprone to cancer and hyper capable
of repairing its tissues
which i argued and my paper was
published in 2002
i argued was a major danger because we
use these animals in pharmaceutical
testing right it's our first line of
defense and the point is
an animal that is hyper capable of
replacing
damaged tissue will not show
toxicity that would be very very bad for
people
so just to say that again and you've
said it very clearly but
it was never the intention of the people
who were breeding the mice for profit to
sell to research labs
to create mice that had the capacity
a greater than usual capacity to repair
tissue
that would have been um actually
criminal right um
that was not the intention so far as we
know and no one has ever suggested that
it was
that ability of the lab mice to repair
tissue at such a higher rate than other
organisms
do was an unexpected consequence and
indeed an unrecognized consequence until
you came along
of the breeding protocol that was simply
an economic
decision right and the problem is
there is the implication that this uh
elongation of telomeres has actually
created a phenomenon where we think
drugs are safe
we release them and then we discover
that they do
damage now of course the damage that we
see most critically is in the heart
we see people have heart failure who
shouldn't and then we start looking and
we discover some drug like vioxx
has damaged their heart probably it's
damage across the entire body
but the nature of the heart is a it
doesn't have much capacity for
self-repair so it's very vulnerable
we could talk about why that is or not
but um
anyway there's that and also failures of
the heart are utterly conspicuous so we
notice them so we you know we think this
is heart damage but it's
it's a more general kind of damage but
anyway it intrudes in the story
of the the sulk institute um
study in a couple of ways one their work
was on
hamsters okay now it's possible they
have sourced some hamsters that have
normal telomeres i doubt it the evidence
suggests that nobody is carefully
monitoring whether or not the animals
they're using as models have long
telomeres or not
unless they're specifically working on
telomeres themselves
so in general people source spice and it
apparently still has this problem this
vulnerability
so what that means potentially is that
as much as they saw damage when they
dumped spike protein into the lungs of
hamsters
the damage may actually have been more
than they saw
because these animals have a unusual
capacity to repair damaged tissue now
it's also possible
that the way they did the study they saw
all the damage
and the animals didn't get a chance to
repair their tissues but
anyway it's at least a possibility but
this intrudes in the story twice because
the other work involved in the thing
cited in that blog post
also uses not hamsters but mice and they
describe
three strains um yeah if you go to that
link
uh three strains of mice that were used
yep
okay and this is this study nature last
year
uh corbett at all yeah um so this
describes the anchor protein
uh that is holding the spike protein in
the
membrane and if you scroll down into
their methods you'll discover that there
are three strains of mice that they use
now
i i don't buy my site i'm not an expert
on buying mice but i did look into these
mice and lo and behold at least one of
these strains sure has the signs of
being an animal with hyperlong telomeres
so actually zach could you put up the
wikipedia entry on the mouse strain that
i sent you
so zach is about to show us one of the
strains that was used in this corbett at
all paper yeah one of the three and this
is just a little spot check i did
oh yeah i can't read that at all but if
you scroll down
to like the characteristics of the
animal okay yeah good
scroll down past history characteristics
let's read that
okay the b a l b c mice are useful for
research into both cancer and immunology
according to michael fastings and breed
strains of mice blabc
substrates are particularly well known
for producing
the plasmacytomas on injection with
mineral oil etc etc
low incidence of mammary tumors that's
interesting that
suggests the other direction but uh they
have
um can you help me read this i can't i'm
trying i'm trying to look at it on my
own screen i'm not sure where you are
it says most sub strains have a long
reproductive life span
are noted for displaying high levels of
anxiety
are resistant to diet-induced
atherosclerosis so this appears to be
a animal that has high capacity for
repair even in a vulnerable tissue
and somewhere on this page it says that
in older ages they're prone to tumors
oh you can keep talking i'll see if i
can find that
oh they are also reported as having a
low mammary tumor incidence but do
develop other types of cancers in later
life
most commonly reticular neoplasms lung
tumors and renal tumors
this is my first view of this at all
obviously this is
this is wikipedia which is often a great
first pass but
we've neither of us done anything let's
just say it is interesting
that a very surface level investigation
of this first mouse listed in this paper
suggests an
animal that gets tumors later in life is
resistant to a kind of cellular damage
and all of that is consistent with it
being an animal with uh
hyperlong telomeres which would be the
expectation unless somebody was
carefully controlling so again the
implications
being that this would be a poor animal
to use for drug
safety research at least right the worst
right the absolute there are many more
implications than that but at very least
you do not use such an animal that has
been modified through a breeding
protocol to have long telomeres
and high capacity for tissue repair um
in your drug breeding protocol unless
you are specifically
correcting for that in your analysis
well
probably i don't know i don't know that
you could because guess what it's the
complex system stupid right like you
know that's where we are
no and that that is going to be the
punch line of this whole thing is
a um the use of these
animals in a way that does not pay
attention to this as a vulnerability
is at the very least deeply negligent
and has
very important implications in our
ability to assess
anything about what the consequences are
going to be in human beings these are
model organisms
yes there's a problem using model
organisms that can't be solved a mouse
is not a person
but that's not this problem this way a
normal mouse could be useful but a mouse
that has had its telomeres elongated
will
consistently it is a systematic error
that will lead you to believe things are
less destructive than they actually are
okay so yes we've got the
issue of what animals were used in these
protocols and then we've got
a kind of
it's a kind of consistent failure that
we frequently see
in biological science where people are
attempting to
make difficult things tractable which is
that they treat this
as a simple system now i think we have
to give them their due
cellular biologists here have learned to
manipulate these systems
effectively but pretending that the
only thing that happens is what they are
intending to happen
is preposterous and in this case
a let's say that the blog post
at the aaas site is
roughly accurate right let's say that
this actually
means that the vaccines turn out to be
safe well and you know so the big
mechanism by which it would be accurate
is
there are many but the one that i'm
stuck on is actually
that uh the spike protein um is produced
in cells
that it it sticks to the cells and that
those cells stay
local and that for instance
when those cells die either by natural
means or
by being attacked by the immune system
because they're being exposed they're
exposing the spike protein
that they that that spike protein is
totally destroyed as well as opposed to
released into free floating space
right so um let's say that that story is
correct and that the damage here is
minimal
okay then that's what we're all hoping
for then this is safe
by accident right that that was a lucky
coincidence because i don't think
anybody predicted that spike protein
in and of itself was going to be
destructive and in fact the mechanism by
which
these guys did right i mean it all did
it did they they came to this
yeah but the mechanism is interesting
and so
let's put it this way those who have
been assuring us that the vaccines are
safe
almost all of them do not did not go
through a process of thinking the spike
protein
would be dangerous on its own but for
the fact that it has an anchor protein
or an anchor sequence at its base that's
going to keep it from getting to the
places that it would do damage if it
were free-floating
i've seen no evidence of that
conversation yes the point is that's not
a plausible conversation the plausible
the conversation was it's a vaccine it's
been through safety testing
it's safe and then it turns out that
well it could well be dangerous because
spike protein itself is apparently
destructive which is a surprising result
a surprising result that goes through
the spike protein causing dysfunction of
the mitochondria in cells
fascinating yeah right a very complex
systems kind of phenomenon i should
point out
all this yeah but the point is i don't
think anybody
would inherently come to this system and
say
spike protein itself interacting with
the ace2 receptor
could cause mitochondrial dysfunction
now we need to check that
separate from the rest of them separate
from what the viruses can't do
so anyway if this is safe it's safe it's
we're just
it's a matter of luck yeah um i i will
say i want to make a
correction um to one thing that i said
last week when again you know we'd only
seen the salk institute
site and not the paper and my
you know we're kind of reeling from the
possibility that the spike protein was
uh was sort of going to be on the loose
right and i do
think that we have reason to think that
even if these vaccines
don't basically keep the spike protein
as contained as we are being told that
that it is that it's going to likely to
be more contained than it is
when exposed to wild type virus i think
that that is
i have i have seen enough analysis
without seeing the actual data if they
even exist
um to think that that is true that the
exposure to spike protein from the
vaccine um body-wide will be less than
exposure to the
protein from uh the virus um but
you know to what to what degree and at
what scale
we don't know um but i think i said last
week you know i've been hoping for
traditional vaccine and boy i'd be first
in line
i still would prefer a traditional
vaccine for
you know other reasons because of the
lipid nanoparticle technology involved
in the
um in the mrna vaccines for instance but
a traditional vaccine would have the
spike protein on it as well and so that
actually that would not address this
problem at all and in fact a traditional
vaccine
might be worse for you with regard to
spike protein exposure
than one of these new mrna or dna
vaccines well i believe i i do like i
want to be
clear that i don't think a traditional
vaccine would actually
solve this problem and might actually
make it worse well a traditional vaccine
might cause this problem it could be
worse
the distinction between the uh
dna vaccine um
and its viral coat and the rna vaccine
here does not marshal in favor of the uh
one of those over the other right so
anyway there's a lot to be said but
overall i mean i don't i don't want to
get dragged out of
the careful area that we have carved out
for ourselves
right but i would i was uncareful right
like i i believe
that what i said um last week with
regard to
effectively i didn't say it quite this
clearly but oh my god this makes me want
a traditional vaccine even more
i don't think that's actually warranted
by this research at all well
i think you know i i remain
favorable to the dna vaccine over the
mrna vaccines
because there's one less kind of novel
technology involved the adenovirus code
versus the
lipid nanoparticle code but this
research anyway the the finding that the
spike protein itself
causes tissue damage um
does not marshal in favor of a
traditional of a of the use of a
traditional vaccine over
either of these uh either these types of
vaccines currently
no but other things here clearly do and
some of them i have not heard discussed
anywhere okay okay so one thing that is
clear i think is that the mechanism of
action
the intended mechanism of action here
where mrnas make it into cells
cause those cells to present foreign
antigen
means that those cells are then going to
be destroyed by the immune system
so one thing that is true is that we
need to have a conversation
about how much damage is being done to
normal healthy tissues in order to get
the immunity is there a level of damage
to tissues that you should accept
absolutely on the other hand how well
calibrated is that
given that we are using a novel
technology in order to get the mrnas
into these cells
how many cells are damaged in the case
where a patient takes up a huge amount
of this stuff into a
disproportionately large number of cells
right are we talking orders of magnitude
difference
how i don't think these things can be
well calibrated given how novel this is
because we don't know you know we don't
know how to efficiently get it into
uh to cells to get the the cells to
display this
this uh spike protein so
even in the best case the answer is
those who told us this is safe and we
know that based on what we've seen so
far we knew they were wrong
based on the long-term unknowns those
long-term unknowns clearly exist
but there's also a short-term set of
unknowns here which won't manifest until
later
if you're destroying healthy tissue
because that's necessary to get the
spike protein displayed
which is necessary to get the immune
system to learn the trick right
then the point is you are borrowing from
future repair capacity
are you borrowing enough to matter don't
know but that's a possibility and it's a
question that has to be asked
just a minor point but i think that
still qualifies as a long-term
uh long-term concern then it's you know
it's
it's a it's a thing that might be
happening right now but if we don't see
it until
until later this is exactly what we've
been saying that anyone who is claiming
that these that any of this is totally
safe
is either confused or lying because we
cannot know and we are not saying that
it isn't safe and we're not saying
um that uh people making those claims
are inherently
trying to deceive you although some of
them may be
simply they haven't been on market long
enough for us to know
and you are providing a possible
mechanism by which there might be
long-term effects
that is effects that may be beginning to
happen now but we have no way to see
them until later
no i would say i want to correct two
things okay one i am saying this is
unsafe
i am not saying it is harmful enough to
matter
but it previously we've been very
careful and we have said
that something that does no harm is not
necessarily safe playing russian
roulette
and clicking the trigger and having no
bullet come out does not
harm you but it is not safe so your
distinction i think
um is or safety is um in the same space
as
risk and harm is the is actual harm
right
so like i do think this needs real clear
language every time you say it because
it's not
these words are not used cleanly by
anyone
and so you're saying i
i understand that there has to be risk
and i am not saying that that therefore
means there is harm
right i prefer the word risk here to say
but i'm going to upgrade that
because i have been super careful about
that and i have said
i've used this example deliberately the
fact that you have put a gun to your
head and pulled the trigger is not
inherently harmful but it is inherently
unsafe
okay so that distinction is the
important one now
i think with greater clarity about the
mechanism of action
when things go right we know that there
is harm being done to tissues in the
course
of action of this vaccine we don't know
that it's significant
it could be that for some reason i can't
see
that the number of cells that are
affected is small and that the amount of
damage is negligible and therefore
you know it's fine well the hope for i
mean i think like the platonic ideal of
what is going
on here is that there's an injection
that is
um that is intramuscular um that hits
as little sort of capillary bed as
possible um the spike pro
you know very little the lipid
nanoparticles do their jobs and so the
mrna doesn't get
um you know released into the
intercellular space but is actually all
encapsulated and goes into
cells spike protein is produced those
those cells on which the spike protein
is produced
stay there and then the immune system
kicks into action
comes and does its its thing um
are any of the cells that the lipid
nanoparticle
encased mrna encasing
mrna actually moving around
maybe um but uh you know if in
again in the platonic ideal of the
situation in which the person who's
being vaccinated is very healthy and the
person who is vaccinating
um by some combination of skill and luck
gets it exactly right and you know does
not hit
um you know part of the cardiovascular
system for instance
there there should be um very limited
travel of the spike protein presenting
cells
post-vaccination yeah on the other hand
the i think given the mechanism of
administration
there is a whole lot of uncertainty
about
how much of anything ends up in a
particular place
right it's supposed to go into the
muscle it's not supposed to go
into the the cardiovascular system
some of it will of course get there by
virtue of the fact that muscle
is vascularized out of necessity
in the same way that other tissues are
but even more so because the
need for oxygen is so high but
but the point is okay so you've got some
needle and it's injecting a fluid that
takes up a volume into a space that
doesn't
have that volume so it's going to do
some damage
and so well no no no no no no no
look this blog post makes the point
here's why this this is safe and it
draws a cartoon
and one of the pieces of this cartoon is
actually
misleading seriously misleading what is
it so the point is
the blog post says it doesn't go into
the
circulatory system of course some will
make it there but basically it goes into
the lymph system
good yeah that's what i would hope okay
goes into the lymph system
and drains into the lymph nodes right
lymph nodes that's good because that's
where the immune cells are hanging out
trying to discover what to fight next
but
that is actually a wrong cartoon right
that's not an antigen presenting cell
bringing a message from an infected
piece of tissue or a pseudo-infected
piece of tissue
into the lymph node that is this
pseudo-virus spilling into a lymph node
now whether or not it has an effect on
the lymph node
depends on whether lymph tissue not t
cells
lymph tissue itself the lymph node
itself and the cells of which it is made
express the ace ii receptor which they
do
so this thing gets spilled into the
lymph nodes which have the receptor that
the spike protein
binds to right does covet do damage to
lymph nodes yes apparently it does
serious damage to lymph nodes so
the whole idea that sort of loosely
speaking
this virus goes into a place where it's
not in contact with the tissue that this
new report suggests is super vulnerable
okay that's good
but how good is it is this really safe
no
it's being spilled into a system that
has the receptor necessary for the
damage to be done
where the disease itself does the damage
which gives us secondary confidence
that this mechanism is actually there
does it inform the immune system when
this thing
spills into a lymph node in its vaccine
form
i don't know it certainly could if a
lymph node
tissue the tissue of the wall of lymph
node
gets the gets the uh vaccine and
expresses this particle the
antigen presenting cells will likely
discover it there and inform
the teeth the naive t cells that are
hanging out in the lymph node that's all
possible but the idea
that we know enough about how all this
is going to unfold that we're anywhere
near in a position to say
yeah this is actually good uh is
preposterous
i agree with that and i also think um
listening to you talk about it i i am
you once again
reinforced in my concern that i know you
share with me
um that part of what is happening is
this you know
ever greater specialization um as you
know as
as as humans come to know more and more
about our world
uh those people who decide that they
want to become scientists are expected
to specialize more and more and more and
more
we have very few generalists who are
able actually to cross domains and of
course now we have people enforcing not
crossing lanes right
um and you know exactly at the same
moment there's all this talk about oh we
value interdisciplinarity and now
there's biophysics and biochemistry and
all this it's like actually
we got more and more specialized we
value reductionism more and more part of
that is again about the
um the bottom line because uh research
is funded
um you know because universities get
more money the bigger the grants are and
the bigger
grants require big equipment and you
know big money work and so big science
gets funded to the um
rather than small science small science
being the kind of work that requires
conversation and thinking things through
you know just it doesn't take that much
money to fund this sort of thing and so
it doesn't get prioritized by
by university so you know that's that's
a whole other thing
but um i believe that part of what we
are being fed part of what is going into
the media and part of what the public is
being fed
is based on some good faith and some bad
faith and right now i'm not going to try
to untangle which is which here
but you know scientists who were trained
as specialists
who really think that because they
understand this little tiny piece of
something
and that you know in this case the
research um is about endothelial damage
right and and vascular damage i believe
as well and you're talking about lymph
well this research doesn't have anything
to do with lymph so you know we don't
have to talk about that in a blog post
about whether or not this has
implications for vaccine does it
and you know that's an error in
the kind of science that we are now
promoting
via this economic model that's entirely
about money and markets as opposed to
actually about discovering of what is
true
so another way to say that going back to
what we
said last week is that
as that as the complexity is faced with
ever narrower tools and some of this is
out of necessity
right you need specialists to wield some
of these techniques because
they're difficult but as that happens
the degree to which you lean on the
precautionary principle should go up not
down
right and so in effect what you're
saying is that
uh the narrow focus of
each of the specialties that is looking
at this is
causing them to be deaf to the
possibility of all kinds of damage that
are on the table
right and so because those things are on
the table a rational person would say
actually
what we know about this is not nearly
enough to say that it is safe
now i would also just i think as a final
point here say that the upshot
of the salk institute paper
and the blog post the upshot is
actually this is a good thing because
the vaccines are creating
antibodies that will block the spike
protein and therefore the damage that
we've just discovered
and i don't think expected that happens
as a result
of the spike protein being present is
actually going to be prevented by the
vaccine
yes that's true after the vaccine
has caused the immune system to produce
those antibodies
the idea that this is therefore good
news
is preposterous as we said last week
the best category to be in from the
point of view of
safety from all of the possible risks is
no vaccine no covet now the problem is
no vaccine and no covet leaves you
vulnerable
to getting covered which is obviously
very bad in its own so it is quite
possible
that and so far as we can tell without
long-term data on either covet or
vaccines
um people
more people a higher percentage of
people have a very bad reaction to
having covid
than have a very bad reaction to
vaccines it is more dangerous to get
covert than it is to get a vaccine
as far as we can tell and by a lot
probably and we can say that
because we don't have long-term data on
what happens to people who get coveted
or the vaccine so that unknown
cancels right because it exists for both
and so i agree if i had to choose
uh between the vaccine and running the
risk of long-term damage or a covet i
choose the vaccine
but this isn't safe and pretending
that this is positive news doesn't make
any sense what they've discovered
is welcome to complex systems something
really interesting happens from the
spike protein
alone spike protein alone triggers a
large amount of damage quite measurable
and that has potential implications here
and it adds to the unknowns going
forward
so um i just i've become
allergic to the assurances of people who
know
something that this is all very safe
based on what they know there's nothing
in what they know that puts them in the
position of saying hey we need to
exercise caution when all the
smart people i think recognize that this
whole system
is out of control and caution needs to
be exercised
for what it's worth um just you know i
do think it is the complex systems and
that's what we've been talking about the
entire time
um but i don't i do think that that blog
post that blog post
felt um reduction of sciency to me and
also somewhat political
and the fact that both the authors of
the paper and their clarification and
the salk institute site
point to that blog post um further
reinforces that sense of mind
but i don't get the sense that even
though the clarification by the authors
of the paper
is a little bit more strongly worded
than i think we can actually know about
what this means
about vaccine safety my my sense is that
they
are um trying to do good work and that
they that they are not
um they are not in this political game
in the same way that for instance the
the guy who wrote the blog post oh i
absolutely believe that too
at least uh the one author yuri who
showed up
uh in a television segment oh yeah we'll
link to that
we'll link to that i don't think we're
going to show it here but yeah but yeah
here's the problem
okay and i must say i have some sympathy
for somebody just trying to do good
scientific work who discovers some
interesting pathway reports the result
and then suddenly discovers that
it's being discussed whether or not this
has implications for whether you should
get the vaccine and they don't want
responsibility for people not getting
the vaccine because then
people will definitely die of of covid
if they don't get the vaccine and they
do get the disease
yep doesn't mean everything but some
people will as a result of that pathway
but here's the problem and i you know i
want to be very clear about this
i won't speak for you though i can't see
how this doesn't apply to both of us
we are discussing the safety or lack
thereof
of a effective
prevention for a disease that is clearly
out of control and which we regard as
highly dangerous
okay that has implications
people may hear what we say decide not
to get
a vaccine and some of them may die
some of them may get sick in fact
somebody else who dies who had no
choice in the matter that's a very
terrible position to be in
the reason that we are in this position
is that the lies
that cause people to believe things are
safe when they are not safe
are vastly more dangerous and you can
see this
very clearly in the lab leak question
which took a big leap in the direction
of mainstream
this week week with uh nicholas wade's
new article
and the very important quote in it from
david baltimore
where he says that the uh the
sequence and the fur and cleavage site
is the smoking gun that points toward
the laboratory
in any case we are getting to the point
where we can now see that what we were
told
about the certainty that the viral
origin was
natural was preposterous for the entire
time
and that those who assured us of that
therefore were telling us something with
a kind of scientific certitude that just
simply
was not justified by anything they could
possibly have known
and so you know that's the context the
context
is a world in which scientific certitude
should be reserved for cases where
something is scientifically certain
and it isn't it's being used politically
to
get us not to think about certain
questions that certain people don't want
us to look into
and you know frankly i would say
we are betting that in the end the
safest thing we can do
is promote honesty in the discussion of
all of these questions that fewer people
will be harmed
if we are simply honest even though the
fact is it will
it's a sword that cuts both directions
that's right um i did want to say just a
a minute or two on this nicholas wade
paper that just came out you can show my
screen briefly zach this is
um he just posted it on his medium page
origin of kovid following the clues
did people or nature open pandora's box
at wuhan
and nicholas wade uh zack may i
thank you um nicholas wade is a long
time science reporter who
is often published in the new york times
and science and this is you know this is
one in a long line of of people
including us from the beginning have
been saying this nicholson baker said it
in january
um we said it on real time with bill
maher in january i went back and found
the first time we were talking about it
extensively was on our 10th episode
on april 25th 2020. it was called sarsko
v2 unintelligent design question mark
and we were then talking about the paper
that yuri dagan had just published on
medium
which you then did a full interview with
him in june of 2020. so both of those
last two are up on youtube and i'll put
them into
the into the show notes as well um so
that's just a little bit and you know
there's been plenty there's been a
tremendous number of researchers
um uh behind the scenes who are who are
who are talking about this
um but we have to point out not just
behind the scenes alina chan in
particular
and rosanna have both uh taken great
risks
and been courageous and absolutely
deserved to be highlighted
absolutely and we've talked about both
of their work um here before too i did
not i mean we've been talking about this
really from practically the beginning um
and you know the virus might have
escaped from a lab
if i had said that and i did say that
you know when we were saying that a year
ago
we were branded conspiracy theorists and
right wingers and loons
right and uh guess what saying that
um doesn't make us any of those things
and it never
did right the reality hasn't actually
changed and
i think what has changed is the social
landscape of
um you know the overton window with
regard to what people feel is socially
acceptable to say and to consider
but the fact is and i said this um i
said this i think at the q a last week
and something that's going to come out
as
a clip um if you don't consider all the
hypotheses
for something if you don't consider it
actually your responsibility
when you're trying to understand a
pattern or an observation like oh
there's this virus that just caused
you know worldwide destruction i wonder
what its source is oh no there's only
one explanation possible
that is anti-scientific right there
that's not conspiracy thinking that's
not
right-wing thinking that's not loony
thinking that's anti-science that is
literally anti-scientific to to believe
that there is one and only one
explanation
uh and to ask questions about whether or
not there might be other possible
explanations
is itself the problem asking the other
looking for the other explanations
and keeping them alive until they have
been falsified
is an important part of the scientific
method it's not the only part of the
scientific method
but all good scientists do that thing
and no one who doesn't that is
no one who says you can't consider that
hypothesis even though
um no one has really looked at it
they're not actually doing science
they may have a credential they may
claim to be doing science but that's not
science
so i do have to wag my finger a little
bit
at uh nicholas wade here no not you um
so first of all i should say his article
is quite good
uh it does a very good job of explaining
difficult material
it covers a lot of really important
ground
i do think there's nothing new there
really except now there are a couple of
new things but in general what is there
is uh nicholas wade's impremature
which uh allows us to discuss this it
has given it another jump in the in the
direction of uh being considerable in
polite company
um but that is you know nicholas wade
is late to the party right and uh
um why am i blanking on his name
um nicholson baker yeah nicholson
baker's uh article covered
a lot of the same ground and i don't
remember how many months ago that was
january it was january
so he was uh he was early
likewise uh matt ridley has been
on this beat for a long time it's like
november
so in some sense as those of us who have
faced
all of that stigma have made it possible
to discuss this in public
we see more and more people willing to
acknowledge what is obvious which is
that this was a viable hypothesis from
the beginning
uh there is effectively no evidence that
has
emerged that points in the direction of
nature and although there's no direct
evidence that points to the lab
the amount of evidence that points
indirectly to the lab keeps growing so
yes it's getting safer and safer to talk
about this and you should expect more
and more people to find their way
uh into the discussion but you know i
gotta say though i was really rooting
for the frozen ferret badger state
hypothesis
oh man that by uh it's the most
delicious hypothesis on the table by far
but the other thing and i can't really
explain this
nicholas wade really screws up
the use of the term theory
and for no reason that i can surmise for
one thing he's clearly seen
darkhorse and i cannot imagine he has
not seen our description of the
importance of this
by calling the lab leak a theory
you are putting those of us who are
taking risks in order to make it clear
how likely this
is in jeopardy right you are putting us
in danger
of being accused of cheating and the
point is we have to be very careful
so this is a hypothesis and
there is no theory because nothing has
withstood test sufficient to call it one
so why on earth given the two words i
just want
somebody like nicholas wade the next
nicholas wade to look at those two words
and when you choose to use the word
theory ask yourself why
you didn't use the word hypothesis and
if you think they're synonymous
then you have some studying to do they
are not synonymous there's a reason we
have two different words
and they actually have a hierarchical
relationship now in some places
in physics for example you will find the
distinction routinely blurred and i
think physicists should clean up their
act on this but the point is this isn't
physics this is biology in biology
this is a well understood distinction
this is the thing that we lean on when
people say
darwin's uh darwin's work is just a
theory
right we always say just a theory
doesn't mean what you think it does it's
as close to saying something as a fact
as we ever get in science right
well stop abusing uh poetic license in
this case and start using the word
hypothesis correctly
and at the point that we have a theory
for where this came from we'll let you
know
all right um we want to talk a little
bit about what happened at evergreen
yes um you want to say something about
portland and i
do i don't know yeah but so we're
already at an hour um
i will do the portland thing quickly but
i don't think we can uh ignore it
so uh zach do you want to put up the
olympian article about what took place
olympian in portland not olympia the uh
oregonian
sorry they have a very similar o in
their logo um
okay so here's the oregonian what
happened is
in uh north portland which is the
fifth quadrant of portland there was a
confrontation
yeah it's very well done it that way
yeah but anyway in north portland there
was a confrontation
and what apparently happened is that a
driver who claims he did not know
that there was a protest going on uh
drove his way
into a weekly protest and this is a
protest that goes on without
permits or anything he drove into this
protest
and was immediately challenged
by protesters now the weekly protest is
to get quote-unquote justice for patrick
kimmons who
was killed by police in a confrontation
in which he had just
shot two people and then came at police
pointing
his gun at them and they shot him 12
times and he died
do we know what justice would look like
it it begs the question a weekly protest
to get justice in the case of a man who
was shot by police under circumstances
that i think and it's not as if this is
simply the police having declared
the shooting justified there is video
from two different angles of this
shooting you can see it yourself and in
fact
zach do you want to go to the other
article on the
yeah the video from the other article
would be good
so anyway it's not the most beautiful
video in the world because
uh yes because it's uh graphic in its
content and because it's surveillance
video so you know some sort of cc tv
thing
um so
he's about to come running
you can see the police over there on the
right you can see
kimmons in the circle running at police
gun out
they shoot him there's video from the
other side so this is a
thoroughly documented instance in which
a man
who happens to be black is shot by
police having just shot two people
and threatening the police but the but
the man who was shot had just shot too
i just shot two people um so
you know but that has nothing to do with
what happened last week
what happened last week was in the
middle of a weekly protest in support of
justice for the guy who was shot by
police
well but it does have something to do
with it in the sense that you have a
weekly protest and in that weekly
protest
you had people brandishing
high-powered rifles so this protest
contained people walking around with
high-powered rifles now i should point
out in some sense the reason that i want
to raise this
is that i have the sense that you know
uh evergreen was a cautionary tale
for portland and portland's a cautionary
tale for
at least the west coast if not the
nation that we are
headed into very dangerous waters
now it happens that the guy who drove
into this protest had a weapon
now i think that weapon was a handgun
and i believe it was loaded
with some sort of non-lethal ammunition
that's how it's described
by the oregonian but he was armed
and these protesters were armed with
incredibly high-powered weapons
now probably all of that is legal
there are two ways that those weapons in
the hands of the protesters could be
legal
oregon is an open carry state
portland prohibits the carry the open
carrying of firearms
but if the people who were carrying the
firearms
had a concealed carry permit
then the prohibition does not apply to
them and if the weapons were unloaded
it does not apply so wait if you have a
concealed carry permit a prohibition
against
open carry doesn't apply to you does
that make any sense correct
are you serious i i'm quite maybe i
misunderstand the law but i believe that
this is the way the law reads so
the idea is the state of oregon allows
open carry um and it has something
called a will issue
oh so but portland doesn't unless so
basically the state law overrides the
city law yeah oh okay okay
um so in any case i can't say that any
of these weapons
that showed up at this confrontation
were illegal if they were either
unloaded even though it was in portland
where open carry is
uh prohibited if the people who were
open carrying had
a concealed carry permit then they are
exempt and if the weapons were unloaded
then they would be legal so
nothing says that this was inherently
illegal but what is clear is that this
is incredibly dangerous
that we are dealing with a situation in
which people
uh engaged in a what i would think
is a preposterous protest in the
interest of justice where it isn't as
you point out clear at all what that
would even
mean right these people are walking
around
with you know with the ar-15s in the
street
some driver who doesn't know that
there's a protest encounters them as
drivers will if you're protesting in the
middle of the street
he's armed suddenly he's surrounded by
people who have high-powered weapons i
mean
you know what has to happen to recognize
the danger of this
right this is incredibly dangerous so
anyway i just didn't see that that could
happen here in portland
and we could uh not
comment on it if i've misunderstood
anything
about what's taking place i'm sure
people will alert me
uh in large numbers i would imagine sure
um but which is which is good
when when we do actually get something
wrong that we hear about it from a lot
of people
uh when we don't get things wrong and we
hear about how we did
we also hear about it and sometimes
sorting through those two um
things can be difficult yeah i'm
positively in favor of the first one
absolutely um it's harder to
to always know because we do get a
certain amount if you got this wrong
it's like
no actually your argument doesn't make
sense anyway
um i also don't want to keep talking
about evergreen yep
right um but uh
boy was there some fascinating news out
of evergreen this week
uh so for for those of you who are
somehow watching this and don't know
that uh
we were tenured evergreen for well we
were professors at evergreen for 15 and
14 years respectively and
left in 2017 under some duress since
then evergreen has been tanking
and um the president
president bridges who brought the whole
situation in 2017
to fruition he really created it it was
that was his baby that was his project
um and you know he'll never admit to it
but he did create it
um he said i don't know exactly when
late last year or something i'm done
i've done my work i'm going to go back
to the faculty and teach
and they've been running a presidential
search and for those of you not in
academia
high level searches administrative
searches and academia are big
long drawn processes and in this case
there's a consulting
firm which has become the thing and
it's a long list of people on the search
committee and all of this
but this came out this week
that all three finalists to be president
of the evergreen state college withdraw
from
process and
it says it's a year-long process that
it's been already um
this is stunning
like this has been apparently a
year-long process sack if i can have my
screen back thank you
um this has been a year-long process by
which they had i forgot it was like 60
something um
applications which is pretty low for a
college presidency
um and they apparently um interviewed
seven um semi-semi-finalists and then
brought three i think to campus although
i'm not totally sure it wasn't entirely
virtual usually usually
even for a faculty position you'd have a
two or three day interview on campus and
meet with the various committees and for
president or for
a vp position you'd have um you
basically have open q and a sessions
with like faculty and with staff and
with
students maybe as well and to have
gotten to this stage
and have and have already been
interviewed and to have all three
finalists step down
is extraordinary i've never heard of
anything like it
and according to benjamin boyce who many
people will be familiar with who was a
student at evergreen at the time and has
been
um has been careful and adamant and
persistent in his pursuit of truth in
terms of what is actually going on at
evergreen
in the aftermath as well as on a number
of other subjects
he says um in a tweet following this um
this reveal quote they've now got an
interim provost last one quit
interim uh vp of diversity ex
equity and inclusion last one quit
interim dean of student affairs last one
quit
and we'll need an interim financial fee
pp current one leaving
so this is not going well
um i want to read a couple of paragraphs
um this is a little bit inside baseball
here i kind of apologize but i kind of
don't but i want to
read a couple of paragraphs um from a
piece that i wrote in 2019
called on college presidents it's an
invited scholarly piece in uh
uh and um let's see i think i've just
lost zack so i can't have
him show uh him show this so i'm just
gonna read
these couple of paragraphs um from my
piece from a couple years ago
perhaps the worst set of fiscal
decisions made at evergreen involves
administrative bloat
in 2015 there were four college
divisions academics
student affairs finance and
administration and advancement
by early 2018 bridges had increased that
to seven
adding diversity and inclusion
indigenous arts and education
and college relations the first two of
these can best be understood as social
justice divisions or pandering to same
the third is public relations academics
was further weakened when the newly
hired diversity and inclusion vice
president was appointed
vice provost a position newly created
and ill-defined
uh the near ubiquity of diversity
officers now on campuses should itself
be questioned as new research finds that
their presence has no effect on the
hiring of other people of color on
campuses where they serve
it's just a parenthetical in my in my
piece having done all this
on may 14 2018 bridges announced that in
service of a
leaner budget and in order to
consolidate activity across divisions
student affairs would be disappeared
mostly subsumed within diversity and
inclusion
and academics would be further weakened
by the addition of yet another vice
provost
and finance and administration would
receive new leadership none other than
bridge's former chief of staff who was
hired without a search
thus further eroding faculty and staff
input to administrative decisions in
short
the administrative legacy of this
president again this is from
two and a half years ago now i'm writing
is to extinguish or substantively
disempower three of four previous
college divisions
create three new ones of dubious value
staffed with people likely to be loyal
to him personally
all while making the unverified claim
that the restructuring of the
administration is a response to the
physical crisis
um so here
are you backsack okay you can show my
screen here here's the prospectus
uh that i find the recruitment
announcement for the president of
evergreen
uh it's it's glossy it almost it almost
looks like the school has it going on
and on page three we have a list of the
board of trustees currently at evergreen
the executive officers which to say
the president and vps and the search
committee
there's a lot to say about this page but
the thing i want to draw our attention
to
is that we have uh
under executive officers one president
george bridges
and um six now
divisions of the college i don't know
what i have not been able to figure out
exactly what has happened there were
seven when i was writing two and a half
years ago
um and indeed the uh personal
acquaintance of uh of bridges is second
listed here john carmichael is vice
president for finance and operations
we have college relations here we have
advancement which was already a thing
and we have the vice president of
indigenous arts education and tribal
relations
and right in the middle of the list are
interim provost
their interim provost and vice president
for student and academic life
academics has been reduced to an
adjective
academics last i checked was
one of maybe the main function of a
university or at least one of two main
functions and
everything else has to come later
right it's academics which is to say we
are pursuing truth and knowledge and art
and beauty and analysis and clarity
and it's the students right so the
students
the student affairs branch of the
college was combined with academics and
then later on
academics itself was demoted even within
the position that exists
for academics the next one down here
is the interim vice president for
inclusive excellence in student success
and zach you can take my screen off here
for a moment so i can say
wow i read that and i thought i thought
inclusive excellence and student success
that sounds like a euphemism to me
so i went looking to see if that was
indeed a renaming of diversity
uh equity and inclusion and indeed it is
um which i found uh when i searched on
the first vp of diversity equity and
inclusion at evergreen who was just
hired 2017.
well she's gone yep um and she has on
her linkedin page zack you can show
um that her position started as vice
president and vice provost
for equity and inclusion in 2017 and
then it was changed to vice president
for inclusive excellence and student
success
uh one year later so this renaming of
things in order to obscure what is
actually going on
i feel like this is a known tactic and
nothing good goes down that road
like inclusive what is it again
inclusive exclusive excellence
inclusive excellence and student success
students
i mean who how can surely you're not why
student success who am i to want
students to fail
right right and you of all people you
should be don't we know that academics
have sometimes been fascists and
therefore anyone who is speaking on
behalf of academics is probably a
fascist themselves
oh my goodness yes did you know that uh
academics and academy
share the same route yeah
yeah um so yeah this is all rather
incredible in addition i mean i think
it's
clear that if any of these folks had
stuck it out
they'd have the job right yeah so
none of them wanted the job no having
seen the place well but having seen them
sorry
but let's point out what that actually
means because
a these are people who wanted such a job
enough to apply
right and to endure the process which is
not simple or easy or straightforward
so they got to this stage thinking that
they would still want the job presumably
they all have access to google and they
know something about the place that they
would have been walking into
but the job is a pretty good job from
the point of view
of the perks i mean it pays very well
as i recall comes with a waterfront
house right it comes
it comes with a beautiful house on the
waterfront in the puget
sound a beautiful office overlooking a
lovely campus
right it's a it's not a bad job except
for
what you have to do and so well
but there's always something there's
always something and i think it is i
mean i don't want to
guess but i've watched benjamin's
analysis of this and it sure looks like
what happened
is that the faculty were
[Music]
uncollegial is the euphemism being used
i think that they were
probably kind of vicious in trying to
ensure
that whoever took the job would sign up
for the bogus story
that the woke among them have been
spreading about what happened in
evergreen which is that what happened in
evergreen
was evergreen was attacked by alt-right
this that and the other
rather than those very people misled
students who uh you know in partnership
with the president
sank the place i've got another i've got
another thing to read to you then this
is exactly apropos from
again and i have just two more excerpts
really to read from this on college
president's piece that i
that was published a couple years ago
that i wrote quote
in the months leading up to the protests
president bridges pandered to the
protesters
privately blamed lack of action on his
provost while his provost was equally
certain that it was the president who
needed to act
and tried to silence dissent within the
college by offering goodies to those who
were speaking out in exchange for their
silence
further you never took those goodies no
i didn't furthermore he empowered social
justice faculty by allowing them to push
through policy changes strong-arm their
critics and make slanderous claims
against other faculty with no correction
or follow-up
for months social justice faculty wrote
nasty and often epithet-filled emails
directed at brett weinstein because he
questioned the way the college was being
run
after which several dozen faculty
demanded an investigation of him for the
mortal sin of accepting an invitation to
appear on fox news
they had become faculty trolls hiding
under bridges
i was pretty pleased with that line when
i wrote it yeah that's awesome um
so you could argue that academics has
long been subsumed
under academics at this college right i
mean certainly that was what was
happening
uh back in 2017 um but
i mean just to follow up on what you
just said who would want that job
and what must have happened you know
they they like you say they all have
access to google
like what what possible reason would
they have had
to not expose themselves to at least
both sides of the story
with regard to what was going on at
evergreen before applying to such a job
like could they really have thought that
even if the people who are currently
driving the school into the ground
are utterly wrong and they are about
their story about what is happening
that somehow uh they could walk in and
save the place
because they're still in charge the
yahoos who who
made 2017 happen are still in charge
with the exception
of the outgoing president who said yeah
my job here is done i'm leaving
well so i mean i don't know how to
describe what i suspect happened based
on
knowing the players that we still know
there yeah but
i have the sense that this is really a
demonstration
you know we said early on in the
meltdown of evergreen
that the lesson of it was that the place
was proving itself
incapable of learning right instead of
recognizing that something must have
gone wrong in order for what happened to
happen and to change course
yeah right it kept doubling down right
it kept doubling down it said not only
were we not wrong but we were writer
than we ever knew and it kept
putting its foot on the gas right yeah
so the point is having done that
to the point that the college is now
down below 50
of its students apparently it's
completely hemorrhaging
all of its administrators right
after having done all of that the small
number of faculty who made this happen
i think they're just hoping against hope
that they can control the story until it
finally exhausts and
something turns around which won't
happen but i my guess is what
these candidates encountered was a
faculty that wanted to control what this
new un
incoming person agreed took place in
2017
which would then tie their hands with
respect to doing anything about it
because if you were going to do
something right and rescue the college
you would first have to acknowledge that
whatever happened in 2017
it did not work out for the best and
having acknowledged that the people who
made it happen would be back on their
heels so my guess is
they're not going to find anybody
tolerable who could actually do the job
yeah i think that's right um
so let me just read the last three short
paragraphs of this
this piece that i wrote on college
presidents this piece that i was invited
to write
and and was published in 2019 you may
show my screen if you like zack
abraham flexner the founder of
princeton's institute for advanced study
wrote extensively on quote the
usefulness of useless knowledge
and in 1939 with regard to germany and
italy wrote
universities have been so reorganized
that they have become tools of those who
believe in a special political
economic or racial creed now and then a
thoughtless individual and one of the
few democracies left in this world will
even question the fundamental importance
of absolutely untrammeled academic
freedom
the real enemy of the human race is not
the fearless and irresponsible thinker
be he right or wrong
the real enemy is the man who tries to
mold the human spirit so that it will
not dare to spread its wings
so i then finish off the piece by saying
we need look forward rather than back
but we arrived here on the shoulders of
giants and we ought to learn from them
in 1871 at his inauguration as the
president of the university of michigan
james b angel who has been credited with
overseeing michigan's transformation
into an elite public university
gave a speech that is still worthy of
our consideration angel argued that an
institution should quote
never insist on the faculty pronouncing
the shiblets of sect or party
all modern institutions should heed his
words well
so evergreen is one
giant shibboleth test and so
too are many colleges and universities
following its
insane lead and where are all the
universities
that could win a honorable academic
contest
who are standing up and saying not here
not now not in my name
where are they yeah no it's it well this
goes back to
uh zero being a special number right it
has to be zero or else
things would turn around so somehow
uh we are stuck all right
uh i think we have arrived there
no i want to talk a little bit about
robin's okay good yeah um
so um we our coyote situation is mostly
um has
has calmed down a little bit but it's
been raining a fair bit so we haven't
been able to try the uh the wolf urine
that was suggested to us so we still
don't know about
about whether or not that has worked uh
the idea being that you don't apply it
uh when it's gonna rain because it just
washes off and it's useless
but what we have seen
is we have we have a lot of birds around
us
and um probably a number of nests we see
evidence that there are stellar's jays
nesting nearby
and robins and hummingbirds although we
have not seen any of the nests
and a couple of crows which i adore
although i feel somewhat differently
about after this week's activities
um uh a few crows showed up in one of
the trees
uh one of the maples over our deck today
uh
this week rather and um
started harassing some robins or rather
got closer to a spot that i couldn't see
very well and the robin started
harassing it
and shortly thereafter i see a crow
flying away being mod by four robins
with what is clearly a baby
something and presumably baby robin in
its mouth
um the next morning
between us we then saw this happen three
more times um
four babies in one nest seems like a lot
on the other hand we haven't seen it
again
and so maybe that was in fact that that
damned crow exhausted the one nest or
maybe there were two nests because
i don't know there to be cooperative
breeding in robins although i should
have looked it up before talking about
this you know why
on what basis were there four adult
birds chasing after this crow and you
know really
really mobbing this crow whenever it
shows up now and um
and you know we don't have them bird
banded or anything so i'm not sure it's
the same crow each time but i feel like
this crow found a meal
found a source of food and came back
repeatedly until it um
until it basically ate everything in
that one nest and right after that
you were seeing um what looked like
territorial stuff
on the ground between two robins that
might have been precursored to
establishment of new mating bonds
uh i will say we know something about
robbins because
back when we lived in olympia we had a
nest that was inhabited two years
consecutively by different species the
first year
was inhabited by stellar stays who
raised three chicks the second year was
inhabited by robbins who raised three
chicks and we actually did some filming
out the window
they had the good sense to build this
nest like three feet below our bathroom
windows so it was easy to see
marvelous got to observe all kinds of
interesting uh behaviors about robins
that i had no clue about before at least
um and in any case so three is a
plausible number
we saw three there yeah and we saw no
evidence of cooperative um like aloe
parenting or anything cooperative
so breeding you say cooperative you know
could be helpers at the nest although
i don't know if such things exist in in
robin's but yeah
anyway something could be a group of
nests just nearby for schooling behavior
could be uh helpers at the nest it could
be
some other anomalous explanation um you
know
crows get mobbed so it could be that
just some other animal
uh joined in in the mobbing but
who knows but it certainly it was uh
fascinating a little bit heartbreaking
to watch this i mean you can imagine and
you know
certainly it caused us to think a lot
about
the fact that for uh i assume this is
not true for all birds but
for many birds uh the safety of their
eggs and chicks is going to depend on
predators who are capable of getting to
the nest not knowing where it is
so how much of the behavior does that
actually drive
in other words are they flying in ways
that don't lead back to the nest in a
straightforward way so they can't be
simply easily observed
absolutely that and you know behavioral
changes for sure and possibly um
nest architecture changes as well right
like so you might you might predict that
um even within a species possibly
although nest architecture is pretty
well conserved within species for birds
but you might you might expect that in
high predation areas you would see
selective pressure towards say cavity
nesting rather than cup nesting
you know cup nests being more accessible
to anyone who wants to come in and grab
your babies cavity nesting being easier
to defend
yeah if you can get through the hole in
the cavity and your predator can't then
that's a decently safe way to go
yeah um yeah so anyway it was totally
fascinating to watch
uh i will say with some embarrassment uh
it was very difficult to get a picture
of
any of this if i if i had seen the first
uh
successful predation i might have been
able to station myself
if i had known that further ones were
coming i might have been able to station
myself and get a picture but i didn't
yeah well i mean it i mean i think
unfortunately you were only able to see
the last one because it happened
very early you know the second two
happened very early one morning when i
was up and
there was no reason for me to pay up but
um anyway i got you up at that point and
you in fact saw the fourth one but it
was that was it yeah
that was it um so anyway a little um
nature unfortunately red and i guess
beacon claw yeah
now we have a little bit of a
predicament assuming that is the end of
the
the robin story that's it okay
um we have just said we're good we have
a
bit of a predicament he just said we're
good not that predicament okay we have
another predicament which is that
things were so busy this week that we
don't
have a good candidate for the thumbnail
here and i'm going to make a suggestion
unless you've got one
ready to go okay so i'm going to reveal
something which is that i was actually
contacted about the possibility of
applying for the job
of president of evergreen but not not
this week this six months ago oh no
yeah and and i it's hard to imagine
hard to imagine as good an idea as it
would be that either
they would uh offer the kind of leeway
necessary to fix the place
um or tolerate me in the slightest so
as i said in a tweet this week
responding to benjamin who asked for me
to apply the job i would have to be
or you you know there would have to be a
guarantee that you could clean house yes
no it's it's hard to mention that
guarantee would not come but in light of
that there was this picture
that evergreen used to use on its front
page it had one of these front pages of
its website it was a rotating thing
where there were you know five or six
pictures in rotation and there was one
that turned out to be me on a bicycle
riding past
the evergreen sign it was quite a good
picture and
at the point that uh things went down in
2017
uh and and we left the place they
disappeared it but i did manage to get a
copy so i'm gonna dig up that copy maybe
we can use that as a
thumbnail if you can actually find it if
i can find it i think i can find it
all right good so uh we're gonna we're
gonna use that one that will be the
explanation for it
okay all right okay well um
so we will be back next week same time
same place we'll be back in 15 minutes
for those of you
watching us live on youtube and um
with a live q a answering your questions
that you pose
uh here and now in the super chat this
hour and next
again we encourage you to subscribe to
this channel like the video
uh subscribe to the dark horse clips
channel and
um share share with people and um
also consider joining us at one or both
of our patreons
where on mine you can get access to a
once
monthly private q a that goes uh for two
hours on the last sunday of every month
and brett has conversations at his
patreon every month again he had one of
them this morning
um totally on fire totally on fire
totally does not surprise me you've got
it
you folks were awesome yeah nice it's a
great group of people
that is that is terrific um so
um yeah maybe maybe that's it for now
and you know as always
i will suggest that you be good to the
ones you love and eat good food and get
outside
totally agree all right be well everyone
[Music]
you